THEY ARE WATCHING.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW COME IN JIM
JORDAN, RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, I GOT TO TELL YOU,
I'VE BEEN AROUND HERE LONGER
THAN YOU HAVE, FOR A LONG TIME,
IN THE CITY, I'VE SEEN A LOT.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE MOST
DISGUSTING DISPLAYS.
IN BOTH INSTANCES, I WANT TO GET
YOUR REACTION.
THIS IS BEYOND BEYOND NOW.
>> YOU HAD IT EXACTLY RIGHT,
WHEN YOUR ENTIRE FOCUS IS ON
ATTACKING AND STOPPING THE
PRESIDENT, YOU CAN'T DO WHAT IS
BEST FOR THE COUNTRY.
YET, IN SPITE OF THAT, THIS IS
THE AMAZING THING, AND YOU HAD
THIS IN YOUR ANGLE, IN SPITE OF
THAT, THE PRESIDENT'S RECORD IN
TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
ACHIEVING GOOD THINGS FOR THE
COUNTRY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I WOULD GO DOWN THE LIST.
REGULATIONS REDUCED, TAXES CUT,
AMAZING RATES, NEIL GORSUCH AND
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH ON THE COURT,
OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL, OUT OF THE
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, THEY
NOT ONLY WON'T WORK WITH TRUMP,
THEY'RE IN TIGHTER MODUS
OPERANDI RIGHT NOW IS TO SLASH
AT HIM UP TO 2020.
WE ARE GOING TO GET INTO THIS
CRISIS AT THE BORDER, WHICH HAS
NOW REACHED EPIC PROPORTION.
BUT I WANT TO PLAY THIS YEAR
JUST FOR CHUCKLES.
MSNBC'S CHUCK TODD SAYS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TONIGHT IS IN
DANGER BECAUSE THEY ONLY REALLY
ACCOMPLISHED ONE THING.
WATCH.
>> EVERYBODY ELSE IS GOING ALONG
WITH IT.
BE CAREFUL CATCHING THIS CAR, IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU ARE PLAYING WITH
MATCHES NEAR A GAS TANK.
DO THEY WANT THEIR ONLY
ACCOMPLISHMENT TO BE PROTECTING
TRUMP?
>> LIKE YOU SAID, WE'VE GOT
NEIL GORSUCH AND KAVANAUGH ON
THE COURT.
OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL, THE
ECONOMY GROWING AT 3.2%, LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT IN 50 YEARS, I
THINK THAT IS A PRETTY --
>> Laura: THAT IS A PRETTY
GOOD THING TO PROTECT, THAT
AGENDA.
>> I THINK IT IS A GOOD RECORD
TO RUN ON.
THE BIGGER QUESTION IS WHAT YOU
RAISED, THE ONLY THING THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO RUN ON IS
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, WHO ISR
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, WHO ISS
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, WHO ISO
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, WHO ISB
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, WHO ISE
FOR ALL OF THOSE GOOD THINGS.
THEY ARE SO FOCUSED ON
ATTACKING, THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
SECRET MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE VARIOUS
KEY CHAIRMAN, THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES, THE WAYS AND MEANS,
AND OF COURSE THE INTEL
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIRMANSHIP,
THEY HAVE THESE MEMORANDUMS,
HERE'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO
COORDINATE OUR ATTACKS ON THE
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE OUR
SINGULAR FOCUS IS GOING
AFTER THE GUY WHO HAS HELPED
COME ALL THE GOOD THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: COULD THE PRESIDENT
HAVE GONE FORWARD WITH THE
MEETING, AND READING SOME OF THE
REPUBLICAN CRITICISM, YOU KNOW
IT IS ALL BUSH PEOPLE, SORRY,
BUT GONE THROUGH WITH MEETING
AND WORKED OUT SOME DEAL WITH
THEM, AND SHOWN THAT HE IS THE
BIGGER PERSON.
WITH THAT HAVE BEEN SMARTER?
>> THAT IS THE PRESIDENT'S CALL.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I THINK YOU PUT
ANY AMERICAN, ANY HUMAN BEING IN
THAT SITUATION, WHERE THEY
CRITICIZE YOU A COUPLE OF HOURS
BEFORE COMING TO THE MEETING,
THEY HAVE THESE MEMORANDUMS OF
COORDINATED ATTACK ON YOU,
EVERYTHING YOU CAN THINK OF,
ASKING FOR EIGHT YEARS OF YOUR
BUSINESS RECORDS, EIGHT YEARS OF
YOUR BANKING RECORDS, ASKING FOR
YOUR TAX RECORDS --
>> Laura: YOU FORGOT DENTAL
RECORDS.
>> WAYS AND MEANS A COMMITTEE, I
WANTED TAX RECORD.
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, EIGHT YEARS
OF --
>> Laura: THEY SAY IT IS
LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT.
>> BEFORE HE WAS EVEN A
CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE.
I THINK THEY ARE NERVOUS ABOUT
THE REAL INVESTIGATIONS.
THE REAL INVESTIGATION IS THE
ONE BILL BARR --
>> Laura: SEE, THEY ARE DOING
THE COVER-UP.
THEY WANT TO COVER UP STRZOK,
PAGE.
>> NEVER FORGET WHAT BILL BARR
SAID.
THERE WAS A CRISIS OF LEADERSHIP
AT THE UPPER ECHELON OF FBI 30
SAID SPYING DID OCCUR.
THERE IS A BASIS FOR THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE SPINE THAT TOOK PLACE
PLACE.
HE USED THE TERM "UNAUTHORIZED
SURVEILLANCE" AND "POLITICAL
SURVEILLANCE" BEER THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO FINDING OUT HOW
THIS CRAZY THING STARTED PAIRED
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE SEEMS TO
POINT TO THE FBI WAS OUT TO GET
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS THE INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS THE ONE I THINK SCARES
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE --
>> Laura: THAT IS WHY THEY
HAVE TO DOUBLE DOWN PAIRED I
LOVE THIS COME OBSTRUCTION IN
PLAIN SIGHT.
THIS IS LIKE A NEW LINGO,
OBSTRUCTION IN PLAIN SIGHT.
SHE REPEATED THAT SEVERAL TIMES
THE LAST COUPLE TIMES.
SPEAKING OF ADAM SCHIFF, HE WAS
WRESTLING WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
QUESTION TODAY.
WATCH.
>> I DO THINK THAT HAS TO BE
WEIGHED AGAINST THE OTHER
CONCERN, WHICH IS, WHAT
DOES AN ACQUITTAL SAY?
BECAUSE THEN YOU HAVE AN
ADJUDICATION THAT THIS CONDUCT
IS NOT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
AND THAT IS THE DILEMMA WE ARE
STUCK BETWEEN.
BOTH ARE EQUALLY UNPALATABLE.
>> Laura: THINK ABOUT THIS,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TRY TO
IMPEACH HIM, NO WAY.
BECAUSE IF WE DID, SENATE MIGHT
NOT -- IN OTHER WORDS, AGAIN, NO
COLLUSION, NO CAN OBSTRUCTION
PEER THE SENATE WOULD COME TO
THE SAME CONCLUSION AS MUELLER
AND BARR.
>> LET'S BE HONEST, THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING IMPEACHMENT, THEY
JUST WON'T FORMALLY CALL IT THA
THAT.
THEY ARE BASICALLY DOING IT.
NOTHING I COME BACK TO, THE GUY
QUIZZED ON THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE A LONG TIME, THIS IS
NOT LEGITIMATE.
WHEN WE WERE IN CONTROL AND IT
WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA, WE DID
LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT BID WE
LOOKED AT WHEN THE IRS TARGETED
PEOPLE FOR THEIR POLITICAL
BELIEFS.
WE LOOKED IN THE SCANDAL WITH
GUNRUNNING AND A BORDER AGENT
LOST HIS LIFE BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE LOOKED INTO THE FACT THAT
WHEN THE TRAGEDY IN BENGHAZI
HAPPENED, AND THEY TRIED TO SAY,
OH, THAT WAS SOME CRAZY VIDEO,
WE LOOKED INTO THAT, AND OF
COURSE, WE ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING
INTO -- BILL BARR IS LOOKING
INTO HOW THE FBI CAN USE ONE
PARTY'S OPPOSITION RESEARCH
DOCUMENT AS THE BASIS TO GO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN PIN THAT
IS LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS JUST AN
ATTACK --
>> Laura: DON'T YOU THINK A
LOT OF THIS IS JUST DANGLING,
LIKE RED MEAT, DOGS, THEY ARE
DANGLING IT OUT THERE.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP THAT OUT THERE
FOR THEIR BASE.
THEY ARE ANGRY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANGRIER PEOPLE.
THEY SAY TRUMP IS ANGRY, HE'S
ACTUALLY IN A PRETTY GOOD MOOD
PAIRED YOU TALK TO HIM.
HE GETS MAD LIKE ANYBODY ELSE,
BUT THE ANGER AND THE FIORI AND
THE SEETHING RAGE IS ON THE
LEFT.
>> IT'S FUNNY YOU SAY THAT,
LAURA.
I WISH EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
COULD SPEND TIME AND ON THE
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE WHEN YOU ARE
AROUND HIM, THE ENERGY, THE
CHARISMA, THE LOVE HE HAS FOR
THE COUNTRY, THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE MILITARY,
HE COMES THROUGH EVERY SINGLE
TIME.
HE'S NOT MAD, BUT THEY ARE ALL
MAD ABOUT HIM.
>> Laura: I LIKE HOW HE IS
NEVER SATISFIED.
4.2% UNEMPLOYMENT, WE WANT IT
LOWER.
I LOVE THAT.